ils sont l embauche à et je le dis de
l'intérieur ils ont été parmi les 15 je
crois que la commission dès leur
majorité nécessaire à l'époque où elle a
été mis sur place parce que n'oubliez
pas qu'on était en plein délire
il ya eu une série d'affaires en rafale
la sphère du royaume seuil et détenaient
de givray la sphère de la cabane à sucre
et plus - récemment il ya eu la sphère
du kirpan il ya eu bon et il ya eu la
sphère de la juge 0 il ya eu plein
d'affaires qui ont commencé à partir de
94 et à chaque fois à tous les deux
trois ans on nous gave et une affaire
qu'il sortait une affaire c'est-à-dire
un jugement
un jugement qui a été rendu et qui était
très favorable à la pratique religieuse
orthodoxes ou une affaire comme ça qui
était dénoncé un professeur qui avait
des congés qui étaient payés et répond
donc y avait toutes sortes d'affaires
qui sortait et je pense que la
commission teller bouchard a permis de
dire bon on va parler on va distinguer
l'ivraie du bon grain les mythes et
réalités les perceptions les réalités
qui on va parler de ça et on va faire
parler les gens parce que nous qui
travaillons dans ce seul sur ce dossier
là moi je travaille dessus depuis 94
en 2007 on était un terrain complètement
connu jeu on savait on avait même un peu
prévu ce qu'elle est arrivée
mais monsieur madame tout le monde il
était pâle atteint donc la commission a
permis de redonner au site y ait au
citoyen lambda de toutes les régions du
québec parce qu'elle est est inhérente
le droit et la liberté de parler de
choses qui les concernaient et qui
avaient été confisqués par les tribunaux
et par quelques experts donc dans ce
sens qu'elle était utile là où la
réserve que j'ai la réserve importante
que j'ai sur taylor bouchard
c'est le fait que la la commission
orridge se pencher sur la place des
religions et des manifestations
religieuses dans les institutions
publiques
à toutes fins pratiques les
accommodements raisonnables pour des
raisons religieuses
comment on traite les uns commandes
raisonnable est-ce qu'on peut alimenter
le législateur pour qu'ils puissent
circonscrire circonscrire les pratiques
orthodoxe c'est ce qui aurait dû être
fait malheureusement je pense que ça
tient beaucoup fait aussi que l'un des
présidents et des philosophes elop
sociologue c'était pas des juristes et
ça les intéressait pas je voulais faire
un débat que sociologue et philosophe
donc avec les résultats que l'on
constate c'est que qui trop embrasse mal
étreint et la commission a parlé de
beaucoup d'autres choses
vous vous rappellerez que en plus de
parler d'un commandement raisonnable la
commission a beaucoup parlé du modèle de
vivre ensemble qu'il fallait préconisé
au québec
est-ce qu'il fallait près de préconiser
le multiculturalisme l'interculturalisme
l'assimilationnisme on a beaucoup essayé
aussi de dresser la liste des valeurs
communes du cadre civique commun autour
duquel les citoyens du québec étaient
appelés à délibérer et à vivre ensemble
donc en traitant de en traitant en même
temps et sans nécessairement prendre le
temps de distinguer les enjeux de
politique d'immigration et ça c'est un
politique d'immigration et d'intégration
et de laïcité
je pense qu'il ya eu un mélange une
confusion des anges et ça ça nous
rattrape encore aujourd'hui